a mind is a brain that's conscious
consciousness is a synonym for
subjectivity and there's a conceptual
gap between subjectivity and objective
observation which is what science is
I would actually maintain that there is
no scientific way to demonstrate that an
entity is conscious it's only apparent
to itself and my prediction is that we
will this is an objective prediction we
will come to accept entities that are
not biological as conscious it's not
going to be okay machines on the right
side around humans on the left if you
talk to a biological human they're good
they will have lots of non-biological
processes going on in their body and
brain those computers will be out on the
clouds so the thinking of that code
person isn't even just in their body and
brain even in the non-biological portion
it's out on the cloud so it's going to
be all mixed up it's not going to be
clear distinction between human and
machine the bottom line is we are one
human machine civilization this
technology has already expanded who we
are and it's going to go into high gear
when we get to the steep part of the
exponential